sont plutôt pas mal
tu as honte une perturbation de la force
c'est vrai qu'on peut pas pêcher ou quoi
dans le code jedi ya rien qui dit
vraiment qu'on a pas loin de pécho un
jedi ne doit pas se laisser guider par
ses émotions
ok ok ok et polémiques
il n'ya pas d'émotions il n'y a que la
belle c'est clair non on reparlera de
ventes en volume qu'en attendant
concentrons nous sur notre mission
mais admettons que manger die en pleine
vigueur de la genèse tombe sur un tweak
beau gosse derrière l'académie et que à
une chose en entraînant une autre
elle y aurait un peu rouler des pelles
tard le des pelles à terek non bon mais
j'imagine que si tu as juste rouler des
pelles c'est pas si grave qu'on ne fait
plus que ça je n'ai pas branle une tête
et du coup tu peux passer du côté obscur
on nous croit pas dans l'émotion où la
passion l'agitation sont des voies qui
mènent au côté obscur
non pas forcément regarder ce wind ou m
oui nous étonne jedi exemplaire il
maîtrise parfaitement ses émotions doit
faire croire qu'ils chantent pas des
meufs mais ce wind où il a un sabre
violès forcément a lover on y est on
voit moins
et un rêve érotique ça compte je sais
pas oui sûrement mais si on sait doigté
qua non mais t'as fait quoi
oh ça va jamais été attiré par personne
toi
mais arrête tu me perturbe la force avec
des questions tiens ça de passer du côté
obscur
parle de moi
c'est cette commande est la colère mais
c'est son rôle en tant que témoin
je veux pas mourir plus tard
nous abandonnons côté obscur vous
pourriez goûter à tous les plaisirs
plus rien ne vous serait interdite plus
rien c'est vous envahir par vos désirs
les plus secrets
on a le droit avec des ebook si c'est
petit jeu là c'est aussi
s'il ne puis-je vous désigne le pechoux
je n'ai pas essayé de taper chaud
une mission encore une